je vais me tourner vers vers d'abord
vers rafael maillochaud on a vu on va
revoir l'image un raphaël voilà vous
avez été agressée là cette semaine voit
la paix ou pourtant regardez c'était
oussama grande armée de crispation et de
tensions notamment entre certains gilet
jaune et des forces de l'ordre puisque à
de nombreuses reprises et bien
[Musique]
on va vous rendre dans quelques instants
donc loyer qu'il ya une tension qui
règne raphaël tt est injuste est ce que
c'est un peu traumatisé il ya les
cheveux soyeux ou quoi surtout avec ses
partisans peu fouillis dame fait quand
vous faites votre métier et que vous
êtes en direct etc raphaël il doit
assurer en direct là il faut aussi aussi
écouter les mecs qui vont sur le terrain
comme raphaël est un mec exceptionnel
qui va sur le terrain qu'est -ce qui est
pas contre vous je vous le dis les gars
nous il y les journalistes et les mecs
qui vont sur le terrain ils sont pas
contre mais au contraire ils essaient de
relayer l'information
et c'est grâce à des garçons comme
raphaël aussi que le mouvement est
relayé que ya des gens qui peuvent voir
les informations et quand il vit ça je
suis sûr que raphaël mine de rien je
suis sûr que c'est un peu trop grave et
que tu as eu peur mais ils n'ont rien et
et que voilà maintenant quand tu vas
faire un duplex tu dis bon il faut que
je fasse gaffe pas forcément c'est pour
ça que j'ai accepté d'une interview
c'est pour parler d'abord de ce que je
vis depuis et maintenant six ans que je
fais ce métier sur le terrain
effectivement en fait pour revenir
rapidement sur cette agression
j'ai commencé ma journée samedi dernier
donc à midi là il est 20h pile n'atteste
l'horloge et à ce moment là en fait pour
moi c'était le moment le moins tendue
puisque je vais d'abord suivi les légers
les jaunes sur le périphérique parisien
et je tiens à le souligner ya énormément
de personnes quand je les ai croisés
quand je leur ai tendu le micro qui
m'ont remercié
merci d'être là merci de nous donner la
parole les les incidents comme celui ci
je veux rétablir d'abord un fait c'est
que je ne peux pas à tester si oui ou
non cette personne avait un gilet jaune
et un sur lui sur les réseaux sociaux
voilà le dit lui-même pour vous c'est
bien c'est que la personne dans son
grand courage quand elle m'a agressé
parce que moi je parle d'agression
chercher une armure de deux trolls qui
m'ont dit sur twitter autres des menaces
de mort bien entendu mais j'ai reçu
aussi énormément de personnes qui m'ont
dit c'est qu'un oeuf etc
mais se faire agresser oui c'est qu'un
oeuf sétif aurait pu aurait pu être
autre chose et je reçois également ce
coup il ya l'art et la reine
l'arrêt sur image le dit très bien on
voit l'oeuvre qui part sur le côté c'est
pas un bout de gilles s est vraiment le
jaune d'oeuf qui parle et je reçois ce
coup dans la nuque dans les services
intérieurs et à ce moment là en fait la
personne
on le voit pas trop non plus avait un
casque de moto avait un tour de cou au
dessus du nez et je n'ai vu que ses yeux
moi je fais mon duplex donc je regarde
la caméra droit dans les yeux et à ce
moment là je vois cette personne qui
arrive en courant je dis bon ça va être
quelqu'un qui va passer dans le champ de
la caméra me parlait peut-être insulter
parce que j'ai reçu énormément des
insultes ce jour-là et audry moment il
lève la main et vient m'agresser c'est
pour ça que je réflexe en un quart de
seconde
à moi de me protéger voilà est en tout
cas j'ai pu voir que ses yeux ça a duré
un quart de seconde
il est reparti en courant et c'est ce
que j'ai précisé dans ma plainte puisque
j'ai souhaité déposer plainte donc le
dimanche et j'ai précisé que ce soit la
police est également à mon employeur et
ma rédaction en chef que eh bien cette
personne elle portait tout simplement
des habits noirs je ne l'avais pas
croisés parce que les gilets jaunes qui
sont derrière en fait je les ai suivis
ça fait des heures qu'on suit ensemble
et cette personne je ne sais pas qui il
est je ne sais pas et ce qu'elle était
hier la manifestation ont été
interpellés
non pour l'instant j'ai pas de nouvelles
de la suite des sujets du cirm à plein
temps